c'est incroyable tout ce qui se passe ça
suffit
[Musique]
avant l'arrivée des jeux vidéo j'avais
plutôt des bonnes notes j'étais studieux
sans être non plus premier de la classe
un enfant normal enfance normale plate
sans vagues crois que la vraie première
vague cc world of warcraft
j'étais au lycée il ya eu des jeux avant
bien sûr avant il ya eu diablo warcraft
et c'est ça reste et ça restait du jeu
vidéo normal parce que c'était des
partis on pourrait faire des parties
mais quand world of warcraft est arrivé
donc un jeu qui ne se terminent pas et
auquel on peut jouer tout le temps là il
ya vraiment eu un basculement je tairai
je suis impliqué dans des guildes ou du
coup j'ai parfois j'essaie con et tu
vois j'ai gravi les échelons jeu devenu
officier dans des guides et du coup ça
m'a presque appris à manager des gens ça
paraît fou de dire ça aujourd'hui mais à
l'époque pour un gamin de 2 15 16 17 ans
est fou quoi tu m'as d'âge des gens qui
ont de 20 à 30 ans alors temps à 15,16
[Musique]
à tort typiquement c'est un personnage
un peu plus arrogant que adrien dans la
vraie vie et c'est un personnage qui m'a
donné de lego moi j'avais pas trop d'ego
de base dans la vraie vie j'avais pas
trop de confiance en moi et c'est
évidemment quelque chose qui m'a donné
beaucoup de confiance en moi
quand ces quelques clés je pense c'est
quelque chose qui est un peu obligatoire
quand tu commences à être regardé par
plein de gens que beaucoup de gens
respectons travail te dis ce que tu fais
du bon travail
au fur et à mesure ça te monte à la tête
alors c'est pas facile de gérer ça mais
mais samassa aussi un avantage c'est que
ça donne de la confiance en soi pour
faire des choses bonjour à toutes et à
tous ici zerator pour un deuxième vod
alors je sais c'est la même car c'est
abusé scandale remboursement tout ça
[Musique]
merci on est à 500% 500% [ __ ] c'est un
truc de fou vous rendez pas compte à
quel point vous faites de notre vie un
rêve et on espère qu'en retour on peut
faire de la vôtre et bien au moins un
sourire par soir le plus important dans
la vie de streamer c'est qu'on a tous
une vision décalée puisque en fait nous
on la plupart du temps on va dire on est
en live de chez pas 18h à minuit à peu
près tous les jours ce qui veut dire que
moi typiquement à minuit ça peut pas
être la fin de ma journée je peux pas
finir mon live en étant crever en disant
bois les lâches qui tout ce que j'en
peux plus les gars et c'est donc pour
être en forme de 18h à minuit il faut
que ce soit à peu près le milieu de
journée
et donc ça veut dire ouais ça veut dire
se lever à 13h se couche et probablement
vers 5 heures du matin et du coup on a
fait une nuit de huit heures de sommeil
comme la plupart des français sauf
qu'elle est en décalé et deux fois
adapté sa vie et pour la vie en couple
aussi c'est pas forcément simple il faut
quelqu'un qui peut s'adapter à ton
rythme de vie ou alors ça veut dire
qu'il va pas beaucoup le ou la voir
[Musique]
où est le wali est ce que ça va être
fait et c'est fait
devant près de 55 mio eur 48 ans soulève
son troisième titre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand on a arrêté dwarf on a dû se
séparer de oued de trois personnes
quasiment immédiatement pas parce qu'il
bossait mal mais juste on pouvait pas
continuer avec eux dans les prochains
projets qu'on avait qui étaient beaucoup
plus petit en terme de dimensions et on
devait réduire les équipes sinon fermez
tout simplement le studio maintenant
c'était horrible effectivement deux pour
quelqu'un comme moi qui effectivement
créé des groupes effet plutôt grandir
les choses l'inde avait régressé et
exclure des gens d'un groupe
c'était ce n'était pas simple web
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
bienvenue à diéval ça derrière moi
pourquoi je fais ça parce que en fait on
se dit moi en fait on stream tous les
jours et on voit la puissance médiatique
qu'on a et on se dit il faut qu'elle
serve à quelque chose d'utile
c'est à dire moi ça me saoule et ça
comment dire ça me saoulait de me dire
ok on stream tous les jours on peut
porter des messages on influence des
gens on le sait et comment on pourrait
faire ça de manière utile va merci à
tous merci d'avoir par son père tout ça
c'est bien
[Musique]
le dimanche soir à chaque fois on éteint
à minuit ou une heure en tout cas on
fait un arrêt très brute du live et
vraiment on arrête tous en même temps et
c'est vraiment on passe de l'euphorie
générale de 48 heures 72 heures de live
à puch d'un coup plus rien tout le monde
tombe et on n'est plus et rate hors
domingo etc on est adrien pierre alexis
et voilà et on est trente jeunes dans
une pièce et on vient de faire un truc
et c'était incroyable et on a la fatigue
qui s'accumule et y en a qui pleurent
parfois et c'est vraiment comme après un
effort physique intense même si c'est
pas un effort physique intense mais en
tout cas c'est un effort mental et un
effort d'endurance et ça c'est des
moments de bonheur purge trop ans
fédérer des gens autour d'une passion ça
c'est un truc qui était vraiment hyper
important pour moi et ça c'est
probablement dans le dos fort kraft qui
encore est un héritage en fait c'est se
dire voilà on est tous passionnés par le
même truc on se retrouve dessus et on
essaie de de s'impliquer tous à fond je
trouvais ça super cool et et c'est aussi
pour ça que je voulais quitter le milieu
scolaire parce que pour moi c'était à
l'opposé de tout ça c'était on est tous
obligés d'être là on n'a pas envie
d'être là mais on fait un peu de notre
mieux quoi mais en fait tu tombes le jeu
vidéo c'est l'inversé on a tous envie
d'être là donc essayons de faire notre
mieux pour ça se passe bien pour tout le
monde